like how have you like dealt with or
helped
recruiters that doubt themselves
like how have you really actually helped
these people
and not doubt themselves without
themselves less
like actual advice around that reminding
them of the little wins
that they're getting every single day i
think a lot of people
for the right reasons are looking at the
long term and
they're getting a bit down because
they've not got a new job in or they've
not got an interview today
or you know something that's that's
quite tangible that we're aiming for
but they're forgetting the little wins
that they've got
and so just reminding them of that and
reminding them that
if they keep doing that every single day
it is going to get them the result they
want
and making it real to them by saying
look this is what i did
and this is how that's helped me get
success so
i think those little wins every single
day just championing them
has really helped people and help help
make it more real and build their
[Music]
confidence